BENJAMIN SCHULER:
SAP systems are often
amongst the most critical parts
of a company's IT landscape,
and therefore, they need to
be protected against downtime
to allow continuous operation
of the entire company.
Google Cloud can help you
improve your SAP system's
uptime and provide you
with different options
for designing high-availability
architectures.
Hi.
My name is Benjamin Schuler.
And in this video,
I'd like to tell you
a little bit about
the different options
that you have for designing
high-availability architectures
for SAP on Google Cloud.
Let's take a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before looking at the
SAP-specific architecture
patterns, I want to highlight
some of the out-of-the-box
concepts that Google Cloud can
offer to improve the uptime
of any virtual machine running
on Google Compute Engine.
Google Cloud is highly
available by design,
with a redundant
infrastructure of data centers
around the world that
contain zones designed to be
independent from each other.
The blue dots on the
map indicate regions
that are available today.
The white ones indicate
future regions.
Zones usually have individual
power, cooling, network,
and control planes that are
isolated from other zones.
If a single failure
event were to occur--
for example, a bulldozer
cutting through a network cable
during some nearby
construction work--
it would affect
only a single zone.
As you can see, every
region in Google Cloud
provides at least
three isolated zones,
which enables our
customers to design
a high-availability architecture
across multiple zones
in the region of
their preference
without being tied to
selected parts of the world.
Since all of our regions
offer multiple zones,
the first step towards a proper
high-availability architecture
in Google Cloud should be
to distribute your instances
across different zones
within the same region.
Our high-performing
network connection
ensures that we
can provide latency
below one millisecond
from one zone
to another in the
same region, which
makes synchronous
replication between systems
a valid option without
keeping the users waiting.
Now that we have learned
about the different regions
and zones, let's
look at some features
that we can offer thanks to
our virtualized infrastructure.
When we need to
perform maintenance
on our infrastructure, Google
Compute Engine automatically
migrates your instance away
from the maintenance event while
trying to keep your application
running without any downtime.
We call this feature
Live Migration.
This happens without
any user interaction,
and is a feature that we
provide free of charge.
The migrated
instance is identical
to the original instance,
including the instance
ID, private IP address, and all
instance metadata and storage.
Another handy feature that
comes with Google Compute Engine
is our automatic restart
of virtual machines.
If your instance
is set to terminate
when there is a
maintenance event,
or if your instance crashes
because of an unexpected issue,
you can set up Compute Engine
to automatically restart
that instance.
This setting is turned on by
default on all virtual machine
instances, and we
recommend that you
keep this feature activated.
In combination with
a startup script,
you can automate your SAP
system start after a crash
without any manual
user activity,
and therefore, reduce its impact
on the user significantly.
In some cases, you might
already meet your availability
requirements by running
your systems on Google Cloud
infrastructure without the need
for redundant components, which
could save you both
time and money.
When it comes to running
SAP HANA databases
in a high-availability
setup, the first mechanism
that comes to mind is
the built-in HANA system
replication.
SAP provides this
functionality out of the box,
and offers a number
of replication models
so you can tweak it to
match your requirements.
For synchronous replication,
SAP recommends network latency
below one millisecond between
the primary and secondary
database.
This means that you can
deploy your two HANA instances
in two different zones
in any of our regions,
and protect your system
against a failure of one zone
while still meeting
the requirements to run
a synchronous replication
between both instances
in that same region.
If you'd like to try such
a setup for yourself,
check out this
link, which provides
some additional
information, and also
a template for our own automated
infrastructure provisioning
service, which is called
Deployment Manager.
This script will spin
up two HANA instances
in two different zones,
then configure HANA system
replication between them, and
also set up a Linux cluster
without any user
interaction, fully automated,
in less than 30 minutes.
Pretty cool, huh?
For scale-out HANA
systems, so a scenario
where multiple
nodes are connected
to form one combined
database, you
can deploy additional
standby nodes that
can take over in case one
of the worker node fails.
As you can see in this diagram,
the data and log partitions
of each node are attached
to a single virtual machine
instance.
In our example here, worker
node two is no longer available,
and the standby node
immediately takes over.
The data and log partitions are
detached from worker node two
and mounted to the standby node.
This is executed
by a storage plugin
that works together with the
SAP Storage Connector API.
The standby node can now
function as a new worker node,
and once the failed worker
node is available again,
it will act as the
new standby node.
With Google Cloud, you
also have the option
to run non-HANA databases.
Check out our database
planning and deployment guides
behind this link.
These databases have their
own built-in functionality
to provide a high-availability
architecture.
For example, a warm standby
server with SAP ASE's Always On
option, or a high-availability
cluster of IBM's DB2 database.
For your application
servers, the first components
that you probably want to
protect against downtime
are the central services.
Similar to the database, these
present a possible single point
of failure, and therefore,
should be protected.
You can choose to run
the different services
on multiple instances, so
have one server running
the message service
and another server
running the enqueue service.
If your message
service instance fails,
the instance running
the enqueue service
can take over with the
latest log information
and continue to allow users
to work with your SAP system.
For such a setup, we
recommend that you
distribute the
different instances
across multiple zones.
One of the benefits of running
your SAP system on Google Cloud
infrastructure is the ability
to provision new servers
in a matter of seconds
and to automate
the entire installation process.
With this flexibility, you can
get new application servers
ready for your users
as they are needed.
And by running
multiple instances,
they can immediately log onto a
different server if one of them
fails.
OK, let's wrap up.
As a general
statement, it can be
said that moving an SAP system
from on-premises hardware
to Google Cloud infrastructure
can improve the availability
through built-in concepts
of the virtualization layer,
like Live Migration
and Host Auto-Restart,
and therefore,
improve the uptime
without any additional
configuration.
Downtimes caused by
hardware failures
can be reduced or
even eliminated
without requiring any
customer activity.
For the database
layer, various concepts
exist depending on
the database system.
Typically, these
concepts are either
based on a regular copy
of the database logs
to a standby system or a set
of database instances running
in some sort of synchronous
replication mode.
For such a setup, the
two database instances
should be placed
in different zones
within the same Google
Cloud region for the highest
level of isolation while
still meeting requirements
for low latency.
And finally, on the
application layer,
the SAP NetWeaver architecture
can provide end users
with multiple
application servers
to ensure the failure
of one instance
does not block all users
from accessing the system,
and that those who
lose connection
can log on via a different
server immediately.
With the flexible infrastructure
in Google Cloud and automated
deployment scripts, a
new application server
can be added on demand, and
placing multiple application
servers in a [? logon ?]
group can improve the uptime
of the application layer.
I hope this brief
video has given you
a better idea about the various
high-availability architectures
on Google Cloud
and what they mean
for running your SAP workloads.
You can find a lot of
additional information
about SAP on Google Cloud
in our YouTube channel
and in the online documentation.
Check out those links right next
to me and in the description
below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]